- The head of high school
suggested an alternative,
which was that I
should only share
white conservative
views on race.
So I should only
have conservatives
who had white skin
- Unbelievable.
- Since that would not confuse
or inflame the students.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a teacher and educator
at Grace Church School
in New York City who
recently wrote a piece
on Bari Weiss's
sub stack titled,
I Refuse To Stand By While My
Students Are Indoctrinated.
And then you can guess
what happened next.
Cancel culture came to his door.
Paul Rossi, welcome
to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you, Dave.
It's a pleasure to be here.
- All right.
So I've wanted to chat with you
since I read the piece,
and we are going to
link to the piece below
and I hope everyone
will read it,
but for people
watching right now
that have no idea
about any of this,
can you sort of sum
up the piece first
and then we'll kind
of get into everything
that's happened since then?
- Sure.
Basically, for the last,
I'd say four to five years
there's been an
increasing change
in the culture of the school
as it started to
implement what it calls
it's anti-racist programming
in the high school that I teach.
So grades nine through 12 there.
And I noticed a series
of very concerning things
were happening there
and basically a
stifling of expression,
to the point where kids
were afraid to be silent,
they were expected to say
things, say the right things.
If they didn't say
the right things,
they were flagged as
problematic in emails.
And a lot of this was designed
to sort of create
a certain culture,
a culture that's
based on critical race
theory, essentially.
So I started to hear
complaints from some
of the students in the school,
some of my own students,
some who weren't my students,
that this was becoming extremely
uncomfortable and difficult
and really poisoning the
atmosphere in the school.
And I witnessed
some things myself
in meetings that were
segregated by race.
So we would frequently
have whites only meetings
and BIPOC meetings,
black indigenous people
of color meetings.
And so as there was
also a proliferation
of opt in affinity groups,
so basically this notion
that individual opinions
and ideas had to conform
to your sort of racial
group and gender group.
And when things
differed from that,
it was seen as anomalous
or not representative of
what you should think.
And I had some experiences
in classes that I teach.
I'm a math teacher primarily,
but I also teach
a persuasion class
where some of the
students in that class
complained of having sort
of a bubble mentality
and they weren't getting any
of the other types of opinions.
So I suggested to my
head of high school
that maybe we could talk about,
we could bring in
some of the ideas
of professor Glenn
Lowry at Brown,
a Brown economist.
I'm sure you're
familiar with his ideas.
- Of course.
- Because the students, well,
a lot of our discussion focused
around the protests and
riots over the summer.
So they wanted to maybe
hear an alternative opinion.
But I was told by my
head of high school
that it would be
extremely problematic
and disruptive to students
of color and other students
if I shared a conservative
views of a black man.
- Right.
To be clear, he happens to
be a black conservative.
- Yes, he happens to be a black,
that was not even in
my initial proposal.
It was simply that he
has certain views on race
and the racial issues
that may differ slightly
from what Grace Church
School is pushing,
sort of a center right,
but still very mainstream
if you look at the opinions
throughout the country.
And the head of high school
suggested an alternative,
which was that I
should only share
white conservative
views on race.
So I should only
have conservatives
who had white skin
- Unbelievable.
- since that would not confuse
or inflame the students.
So I didn't even
respond to that email.
I wound up not even
teaching that unit at all.
And I just, I was so
disgusted by that response
which I just see as
self-evidently racist.
The notion that the
dissemination of ideas
should be filtered based
on the color of the skin
of the person who's
speaking them.
And it's just completely
anti intellectual
and regressive, in my opinion.
Subsequent to that,
there was a self care
meeting during the pandemic
which was ostensibly
designed to help students
cope with the
struggles and problems
with being at home stuck,
maybe they're not
able to come to school
more than twice a week.
And in this meeting
up came the white
supremacy slide
saying that some of
the characteristics
of white supremacy
culture included things
like objectivity,
and individualism,
and most interestingly
enough, a right to comfort.
So in the segregated
whites only meeting
that was supposed to
be teaching students
how to feel more comfortable
with the events that
were surrounding them,
they were told that
if they were white
they should question
their right to comfort
which I found the
height of irony.
So then the facilitator
who was actually very nice,
we got along quite
well I thought,
asked the group of 200 students
and maybe 30 of my colleagues
whether they might be feeling
a white feeling
around these topics.
And at that point, I
decided to question
what that actually
meant, a white feeling.
Like, what makes
a feeling white?
And I was a little
miffed and concerned
because I thought that
this was blatantly racist
but I was going to try
to present my questions
in a way that
wasn't antagonistic.
And later she did
speak to me and tell me
that she didn't feel
that my questions
were offered in bad
faith or anything.
So what I wanted to do
by asking the question
was to open up the
discourse a little bit
so that students may
see me as an example
and maybe model for them that
it's okay to question ideas.
It's okay to have
different viewpoints.
And that's exactly
what happened.
So students in the chat
window of the Zoom meeting
started to ask a broader
range of questions.
Even faculty joined in with
some questions of their own.
The facilitator allowed it.
So there were a lot of
questions against capitalism.
So I put my own idea
about capitalism in there
which was that capitalism
is extremely anti-racist
since it's done more to
lift people out of poverty,
lift nonwhite people
out of poverty than
than any other of
its competitors.
Some of the questions
that I put in
also questioned the nature
of racial identification at all.
Like, why should I
identify as white?
Why should I
introject an identity
based on how other
people see me?
Why is that necessary?
And so that comment
and some others
made their way out
of the meeting,
sort of violating the
norm of confidentiality
to some folks that were not
in the whites only meeting
and caused some
concern and agitation
and then they had to have
meetings about the meetings.
And then it was sort
of a week and a half
of upheaval, processing.
People felt harmed.
I was brought in to speak
to my head of school
and the assistant
head of school.
And I was asked how I felt
about what I had done.
And I actually felt great.
So I said, "I'm not contrite.
"Apparently people are
claiming that I've caused harm,
"but no one has come to
me to express this harm."
And they couldn't even
explain the causality
of how my questions could
have caused the harm
in the first place.
And they kept raising the stakes
when they noticed that
I wasn't contrite.
And they said, "Well,
you've caused grievous harm.
"You've disturbed the
student's peace of mind."
And then at the end,
when I wasn't contrite,
they said, "It's raised to
the level of harassment."
And at that point I
just ended the meeting.
I had a subsequent meeting
with the head of
the whole school
and he reiterated
his disappointment.
He had some pre-textual
reasons for being upset
but clearly what was
causing the problems
in the school were the
nature of my questions.
Not necessarily some of
the pre-textual things
that surrounded it.
- Okay, so there
there's a lot there.
And I know that for
my main audience
that maybe hasn't
heard about this yet,
everything you're
saying is probably
not that shocking to them,
because I think so
many people have
now seen this sort of woke thing
infect so many schools and
high schools and colleges
and now virtually every
institution and everything else.
So all this is happening.
And was there a
moment where you,
like, what was it in
you that was like,
I have to say something now?
Because I think a lot of people,
the question of
the day is sort of
what makes people stand up?
'Cause I think we're watching
a lot of people fold,
and I'm glad to see that not
only did you write the piece
and got in touch with Bari,
and I'm curious how
that happened as well,
but then are willing
to do press after
and really keep walking
through the fire on this thing.
- Well, once it
started to cascade
I began to feel a real
sense of exhilaration
and duty that I was
doing the right thing.
So that carried me through
up until the present day.
I wasn't sure when I started
to ask what a white feeling was
or ask these things in the
chat, how it would play out.
I hadn't planned it.
It started something.
My impulse to do
those things initially
was simply to provide,
those questions were genuine,
but I asked them because
I felt that students
needed to see a teacher,
an authority figure,
model for them how free
discourse is conducted.
And I hadn't seen
anyone do that before.
And I felt that this was
something that I could do.
And as it started to cause
all of this chaos around me,
I realized, well, this is
actually pretty important.
And the more chaos was going on,
the more I actually felt that
it was important to pursue it.
- Yeah, I mean, it's
so extraordinary
because obviously,
you know the story
of Bret Weinstein at Evergreen
and so much of my audience
knows that story of course.
And we've heard so
many versions of this.
So then how did you
get in touch with Bari
and how did this whole
article get written
and the whole piece there,
the public part of this not
just fighting back internally?
- Well, my contract, they
offer a contract year to year,
and so in my current contract
expires the end of August.
So I had to sign the
contract for the next year
by April 15th.
And part of the contingencies
of that contract
were that I attend a
restorative practices
designed by the office
of community engagement
to address the harm
that I'd caused
students of color and other
students in the school.
But they would not specify
what those practices would be
until after I signed.
So I was in a bind there.
So I found
- Incredible.
- some legal representation
through FAIR,
the Foundation Against
Intolerance and Racism.
I spoke with Bari who's
on the board of advisors,
and she suggested that I write
a piece about my experiences.
And I wrote 5,000
words at first.
I had a lot to say. And
then we edited it down
to something that
was more digestible.
And then I did another draft,
and then she had some tweaks.
So the editing was very helpful,
but those were all my words.
And I'm really pleased
with the effect it's had.
- So, okay, so you
put the piece out
and then the hate starts coming.
You get support from
some quarters of course,
but then the hate
starts rolling in.
And then what's the next
thing that the school did?
'Cause this is where
it really starts
kind of going off the rails.
- Well, it is interesting.
I mean, I got
overwhelming support,
predictably, through
Bari's subscribers
and through an email
that I had placed there
but I was curious how
the school was reacting.
The article came
out on the 13th,
my contract I had
to sign by the 15th.
I hadn't gotten
back to them yet.
And then on the 14th, I believe,
I received a threat from someone
within the school community.
It was not a physical threat
but it was a threat to my
livelihood, my wellbeing,
and it was basically
everything but
So I reported the threat
to the administration.
I reported it to
the head of school.
And then they tried to
use that as a pretext
to keep me out of the school,
to keep me from
teaching in the school.
Saying that, "Maybe you feel
unsafe because of this."
And I said, "No, actually
I don't feel unsafe.
"I'm merely bringing
this to your attention
"to something on your radar
you should take care of."
And then they tried to reframe
this threat as an opinion.
And they said they
would poll the opinions
of the other
students and faculty
to see if they felt safe
with me in the building.
And so when they came
back to me and said,
"No, actually your students
"don't want to be
in your classes
"so we need to keep you home.
"And in fact, we're going to
take away all your classes."
- Unbelievable.
- So they were
indifferent to my claim
that actually if
someone makes a threat
aren't they the ones that
should be staying home?
Why is the teacher punished
for what another person did?
- Unfortunately, my
lack of shock is just,
well, not only because
I know your story,
but I mean, we know this
story over and over again,
sort of false allegations
then gaslighting
and reversing accusations
and all of these things.
Okay, so we're going to
play this audio clip now.
Can you just set up what
happened between you
and the head of the school
to give a little context
and then we'll play
and then come back?
- Sure.
So the head of school,
George Davidson,
sent a letter to
the whole community
saying that in my article
I had misrepresented
the conditions at the school,
that I had substantial
omissions in there,
and they reiterated their
commitment to anti-racism,
and they relayed to the
school that they had
offered me this
chance to participate
in a subcommittee of a committee
that would be
heavily supervised.
So, as to sort of try to
co-opt what I was saying.
However, their claim that I had
misrepresented things
or left omissions,
I responded to that
with my own letter,
saying that I actually had
in conversations with George,
he had clearly
acknowledged to me
that he had grave doubts
about the school's own policy
and that he
specifically had said
that there was a problem
with demonizing
whites at the school.
So I released that
letter publicly
in response to his letter.
And then he released
a letter back
saying that this was, in
his words, I misquoted him.
I attributed to him
things he had never said
nor would ever say in the press.
My actions were unprofessional.
So he was impugning my
character and my veracity.
So at that point I
felt I had no choice
but to release clips
of the conversation,
which I had recorded,
because I was worried
that it might come up
in an employment dispute.
- Right, it's actually
quite incredible
because you did this
like an absolute pro
in terms of the
emails back and forth
and then doing this recording.
And well, let's let the
recording stand on its own.
So let's throw to that.
- [Paul] Let me ask
you something, George,
because I think there's
something very different
about having a single experience
where you make sense of it,
and having a teacher,
an authority figure
talk to you
endlessly every year,
telling you that because
you have whiteness
you are associated with
all these different evils.
These are moral evils.
It's not the same as taking
like a physical thing
because it doesn't
affect your moral value.
That's the problem.
- [George] The fact is
that I'm agreeing with you
that there has
been a demonization
that we need to get
our hands around
in the way in which people
are doing this understanding.
- [Paul] So you agree that
you were demonizing kids?
- [George] We're demonizing
white people for being born.
- [Paul] And are some of
our students white people?
- [George] What?
- [Paul] Are some of our
students white people?
- [George] Yes
- [Paul] Okay, so we're
demonizing white kids.
Why don't you just say it?
- [George] We are using language
that them feel less than
for nothing that they are
personally responsible for.
- Okay, so that clip
is quite extraordinary
because in essence
he's basically saying,
yes, you're telling the truth.
- Yes.
- So you must have felt
kind of good, I guess,
at that point that
you released it.
- Yeah.
I mean, if you back
me up against a wall
and you call me a liar,
well, he left me no choice.
I have a reputation
that I have to protect,
especially since I'll probably
be looking for another job soon.
Additionally, I
want to make clear
that the word
demonization was his word.
I never suggested it to him.
That's why I was
actually quite shocked
that he felt that way.
And I was also shocked
that he hadn't taken
any action on it because
what does it mean
if the head of school knows
that students are being
demonized for their race
and does nothing except
share it privately
and saying publicly something
completely different?
So this was just, it
was gratifying in a way
which is why it kind of
said, thank you, thank you.
But it was also
really disturbing
because nothing had been done
or seemed would be
planned to be done.
He did make some
mention about they were
going to have a meeting
at the end of the year
or something about it
but that seemed
totally inappropriate
to how serious the problem was.
- Right.
So to bring this all
to now, actually,
so there was a little confusion,
I think at first,
whether you had been let go
or exactly what had happened.
So you are still
employed by the school
but they're just not
letting you teach,
is that correct?
- That's right, that's right.
As of now, I still
have email access.
I don't receive all
of the communications.
I'm not on all the
distribution lists,
as it turns out,
but at this point
I still am connected to
the school in that way.
I have been asked to
be on this task force
but I think I've said
all I really need to say
for them to work
it out themselves.
Frankly, I don't
think there's much
I need to add to that.
- Do you think
there's any chance?
I mean, they've sort
of just in essence
doubled down, even now
after having him be exposed.
I mean, do you sense
that there's any chance
that they will
reverse any of this?
Is there any evidence?
I mean, this is one
of the key points
of the whole woke thing.
They don't seem to
respond to truth
and almost in every
case they double down.
- Yeah.
They have put themselves in
a very precarious position.
And you know the expression
between a rock and a hard place?
Okay, this is like that,
but instead of being crushed
they're being pulled in
two opposite directions.
So they've racialized
the atmosphere so much
and promised so much
to different groups
that now it's
almost like I wonder
if they would, at this point,
be able to reverse course,
given how deeply they've
sunk their commitment
into this divisive ideology.
I don't know if it's a
problem that can be solved
by changing course
at this point.
- Right.
In essence, they can't,
because they've gone so
deep on teaching this stuff,
that it would basically
point all of the light,
shine all the light on them.
So what do you want to
happen at this point?
I mean, if you got an
email right now saying,
hey, you can come teach
again, is that enough?
- No, I want them
to change this.
I want them to actually.
I don't want the
school to be destroyed.
I don't want to put vulnerable
students on the street.
I want to simply allow for
greater viewpoint diversity,
to have all students feel free
to express their points of view
and have them discussed openly
in a spirit of open inquiry,
not to have their
comments judged
simply by the color
of their skin,
which is what happens, I think.
And with a lot of students,
their points of view
are labeled as one of group
of activist students labeled,
white opinions,
simply because they're
uttered by a white person.
I think they need
to completely revamp
the entire culture of the school
to allow for open inquiry.
And that's what students
have been asking for
to me personally.
So I think that's
really important.
I don't want the
school to go bankrupt.
I want the school
to be a good school,
and that's how they could do it.
- Are you shocked where
you've gotten some support
and dismayed where you
haven't gotten some support?
- I'm overwhelmed by how much
support I've gotten, frankly.
I was expecting it to be like
half hate and half support.
I would be happy if
that's what it was
but I think the people
that have reached out to me
have been overwhelmingly
supportive.
Parents, alumni at
the school, students
have said, "Thank you
so much for saying this.
"Now that I'm in college,
"I look back on my high
school and I feel like
"I remember feeling
scared to say,
"to express myself
in these classes."
I think there are students
at the school now,
I think there's a
substantial percentage
of students at the school
now that are in support
if not with my views,
with my right to speak up.
And they have supported
my right to speak up.
Now they can't do it
publicly, they're students.
But I have ways that people
have communicated to me.
So that inspires me,
that actually gives
me a lot of hope
that perhaps the worm is turning
and we'll see some changes,
if not at Grace, but maybe
in some other schools.
We'll see.
- Yeah. Well, as I said to
you right before we started,
everyone that has
been on my show
that I've seen step
through this thing
and walk through that fire,
they're always stronger
on the other side
whether it's Bret Weinstein
or Lindsay Shepherd
or even James Damore,
anyone that's done it
from an academic angle
or James did it
obviously at Google,
whatever it is, if you
can get through it,
then you're pretty much okay.
If people want to find
out more about this
or help you or reach out to you,
as you said, you might be
looking for a job soon,
where can we direct them?
- You can email me at the email
teachingfortruth@gmail.com.
I am the only one that
has access to that email.
No one else will see
what you send me,
and I will keep every
everything confidential, if so.
And I also respond to
every email that I get.
So please reach me there.
I'm also volunteering
currently for FAIR,
the Foundation Against
Intolerance and Racism.
And we're working to set
up chapters nationwide
with parents and
students, and other people
to basically push back and
create a common culture
based on fairness,
understanding, and humanity.
We have to get back to a
sane approach to education.
And I think FAIR can help.
- Yeah.
And FAIR basically is
stepping into the vacuum
where the ACLU
which unfortunately
has kind of crumbled
under a lot of these ideas
has just left the
range, so to speak.
Well, Paul,
I really appreciate you doing
this and I wish you luck.
And if there's anything
I can do to help you
along the ride,
please let me know.
- I think you already have
Dave, this has been great.
Thank you so much for having me.
- All right, great. Thank you.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about academia
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.